there's one thing you and I have in
common let me tell you what it is when
you and I were born both of us we were
horrible at everything we had no idea
how to talk how to walk how to crawl how
to eat how to drink we didn't even know
how to prove the doctors have to make
sure we learn how to prove so what
happened how do we learn all this stuff
how do we learn how to talk in math and
language how do we learn how do we learn
how to make foam how do we learn this
stuff I don't all the subject place well
most people eventually become good at a
lot of things we're good at talk and
walk and running speaking community
we're good at it some become great at it
but only if you become masters at it
masters of their industry masters of
their trade and here's the difference
the difference is for the person that
becomes a master it matters to them a
little bit more there's a person that
becomes a master they don't just want to
become masters it's a must
it's a half-two it's right up there as
oxygen I need oxygen to survive I need
to master what I do it's gotta be done
important to them and listen I'm not
expecting everybody to watch us to say
the hell is he talking if you'll
Atlantis this makes a lot I'm expecting
most people to say he's out of its
flippin mind are you crazy that's the
part about becoming a master some will
call you crazy so we'll call you mania
some will call you nuts but everybody
will respect you everybody will respect
you history books respect ministers they
do history books have respect a lot of
respect for people that master trade so
I got one question for you to wrap it up
you're with do you just want to be a
master at what you do you just want to
be good just want to be kind of cool and
everybody says oh my god he's so great
you so great but you want to beat expand
you at the highest level people say
phone my gosh he or she took it to a
whole different level
and by the way there's only one person
that can answer that question
nothing that's your parents not sure
husband
not sure why much of words on that you
grew up and that's your best friend only
one person you know that is
[Music]
you